I was the first person I ever hang from
a helicopter I didn't realize that the
helicopter was going to create
turbulence and it was excruciatingly
painful I did it as like Mind Over
Matter kind of thing to try to inspire
people that anything is possible yeah
and then prior to this I hung for 6
hours in Time Square and you know you've
seen all things in Time Square but when
you see a dude hanging for 6 hours in
the middle of Broadway and 43rd people
looking at me and like in a puke because
the skin dist stretches I spent 24 I was
on the water but I was so desperate to
achieve what I had in my head that I
didn't give a what the consequences were
that's how bad I wanted to succeed in my
life I just was willing to die from my
art